[Applause]  [Music]  alright first things first is I talk  funny so sorry if you can't understand  me I'll try and talk slowly and make  sure you can understand the words I'm  saying first of all I'm going to talk  today about this concept of intellectual  property because what we used to  thinking of is physical property and  that's something tangible so it's you  know a house or the clothes you wear  it's it's a thing that you can see and  feel and touch intellectual property  creations of your mind so we have  inventions which is what I'll talk  mostly about today but also other things  like artistic works designs symbols  logos images all of those things are  what we call intellectual property  because they're things that were created  with your mind